what a plug we're back
New York City
pretty intense 200,000 days death to
Asia and back safely
really productive super excited about
what's going on there
hey guys this is going to be an
incredible video I'm so fascinated by
hiring and building businesses this is
one of the most interesting exchanges
I've ever had in a conference I had this
in Singapore
it was incredible back and forth and
there was an insight that I unlocked
that I genuinely believe will help so
many tens of thousands of you have a
better business going forward so who are
you doing this supply and the demand
side the most interesting thing that
I've heard somebody say in a long time
because you're a hundred percent right
and it blows my mind that almost nobody
talks about it okay so here's my issue I
don't have any problem with a demand
potion okay okay the minute I go out
there I open my mouth I'll get I'll get
the business you don't know how to fill
the pipe yes and I don't know how to
duplicate myself because you can't I
don't know if you heard yes I know that
but I mean do I really really need to
automate by business you have been
duplicating with us that I can go home
and have a holiday I understand it so
why there's only two things holding you
back your inability to operate or your
ego so we just have to dissect it with a
couple questions what do you sell
I mean consulting great why haven't you
hired more people to consult I have good
but they're just not up to it
this is not up to the level hold on up
to whose level yours or the clients the
level that I set as a basis to benchmark
and what I got four months of it so so
you real quick who's hiring these people
me okay
so let's play this game together
all right what's what's about to happen
is you're about to get exposed to
yourself and then you'll be able to win
you're playing a very fun game of you've
got a big [ __ ] ego I mean it
you've got to wrap your head around this
you're hiring you've created an
arbitrary benchmark that nobody's
hitting because you put yourself on a
pedestal at the mercy and the detriment
of building a bigger business because
you want to sell fulfill that you're so
much better
play with me
you can't think about what you I'm not
my standard so don't don't scale them be
a one-woman shop I can do more I believe
we should do we get this I mean I've got
the models
I've got everything there I've basically
templates that everything that I do so
all you need to do is take the template
follow the SOP and let's go out hit the
market how many employees have you had
at the height 12 and how many of you now
do and was a customer's firing or their
me you and at one point the early this
year everyone left and I'm fine with
that
why because they realized that it was
the wrong place for them to be and I
realized that I can't
that's no point for me to keep anyone
when they can't do the job and I'm I'm
prepared I know that have you thought
about the possibility of you being a
great consultant but a terrible boss I'm
asking I'm asking I have that repetition
I know okay thanks for answering
look I think you have being serious with
you and the reason I went right at it I
want you to win it's a game of ego what
people don't understand is that is the
problem for all the the reason I've been
able to scale vaynermedia many think
that I have an ego I play on confidence
which is what allows me to scale because
I don't hold everybody to an arbitrary
metric that has no reality other than
what's playing in my own head to me you
your if you're the one firing or they're
quitting because the work environment is
exhausting because you keep pounding the
drum of some fake Mendoza line of
quality needed that you are the judge
and jury of and it's some interpretation
of how you decide they follow the
template you're just scratching your own
ego of how great you are at the
detriment of your business the reason I
have 800 employees and high retention is
I don't hold any of them to my standard
because they don't need to be me to
build an actual business you need to
decide if you want to build a one-woman
shop or an actual business
and can I tell you something there's
nothing wrong with the one-woman shop
the way your scale is you may charge for
content you may write a book you may
start getting paid more to speak you
don't maybe you don't you know what I
mean and one even when I say when I see
you react you don't mean to build a
40-person consulting shop because maybe
you don't like it it's not that you're a
bad person it's that you don't want to
lower your standards and if you're stuck
in that well then monetize a different
way by expanding a more around you
versus trying to build out an actual
business around it you know what I mean
and that's ok doesn't make you a bad
person as a matter of fact you'll
probably be disproportionately more
successful because you're being
self-aware and enjoying being the one
person band and making your money that
way you don't have to build vaynermedia
you don't to build being a McKenzie be
you and be your best self your way and
enjoy ok easily one of the best videos
for so many of you so the question of
the day is did this help you and more
importantly what are you gonna do about
it see this
and your gums win it when the fire takes
over blood is running as the battle gets
closed